WEEDS.
MOST AMERICANS, I THINK, CAN
UNDERSTAND.
>> OH, YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
EVERYONE STICK AROUND.
>>> THERE IS SOME NEW REPORTING
TONIGHT ON A NAME THAT HAS COME
UP IN PAST COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
SENATOR RON JOHNSON, TODAY CNN
TRIED TO SPEAK TO THE LOYALIST
OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT THAT HE
WAS INVOLVED IN THE FAKE
ELECTION SCHEME.
REMEMBER, REPORTERS TRIED TO ASK
HIM ABOUT IT LAST WEEK AND THIS
HAPPENED.
>> SENATOR JOHNSON, HOW MUCH DID
YOU KNOW ABOUT WHAT YOUR CHIEF
OF STAFF WAS DOING WITH THE
ALTERNATE SLATE OF ELECTORS?
>> I'M ON THE PHONE.
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT.
I CAN SEE YOUR PHONE.
I CAN SEE YOUR SCREEN.
>> Reporter: DOES YOUR CHIEF OF
STAFF STILL WORK FOR YOU,
SENATOR?
>> WHY WAS THE CHIEF OF STAFF
EVEN OFFERING THIS TO THE VICE
PRESIDENT?
>> GUYS, THIS IS A COMPLETE
NON-STORY.
WE'VE ISSUED THIS COMMENT.
>> JOINING US NOW, CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MANU RAJU.
ONE OF THOSE REPORTERS WHO
CHASED DOWN SENATOR JOHNSON
CAUGHT UP WITH HIM AGAIN.
WHAT DID SENATOR JOHNSON HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT TODAY'S HEARING?
>> Reporter: NOTHING, ANDERSON.
IN FACT, ON THE WAY IN AND ON
THE WAY OUT OF AN EVENT HE HAD
THIS EVENING IN MILWAUKEE, I
TRIED TO CATCH UP TO HIM, TRIED
TO ASK HIM ABOUT THE HEARING AND
WHAT HAPPENED LAST WEEK.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
AT ONE POINT HE SNUCK OUT THE
BACK OF AN EVENT ROOM AND
DECLINED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
WATCH.
>> Reporter: SENATOR JOHNSON, DO
YOU HAVE TIME FOR QUESTIONS,
PLEASE?
>> Reporter: SO HE HAS BEEN
UNDER QUITE A BIT OF PRESSURE
OVER THE FAKE ELECTORS ISSUE
THAT YOU MENTIONED, AND THEY
REVEALED LAST WEEK THAT THEY
SAID THE SENATOR WANTED TO HELP
IN THE FAKE ELECTION.
HE HAS DOWNPLAYED THAT WHEN I
ASKED HIM ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS,
BUT HE ALSO DOWNPLAYED JANUARY 6
SAYING IT WASN'T AN ARMED
INSURRECTION.
WHEN I TRIED TO ASK HIM ABOUT
THAT AS WELL, ANDERSON, NO
RESPONSE.
>> HIS COMMENT THAT IT WASN'T AN
INSURRECTION, THERE WEREN'T
WEAPONS, ALL THAT SORT OF THE
STUFF, IT LOOKED PARTICULARLY
BAD TODAY.
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE HE WOULD
WANT TO TRY TO FLEE EVEN THOUGH
HE DIDN'T USE THE PHONE EXCUSE
THIS TIME, MANU.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT.
AND HE'S UP FOR REELECTION IN A
VERY DIFFICULT RACE AS THE
PERENNIAL SWING STATE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE COME AFTER HIM ON
THIS ISSUE.
SEVERAL OF THE OPPONENTS IN THE
FALL HAVE CALLED ON HIM TO
RESIGN, EVEN CALLING HIM A
TRAITOR TO THIS COUNTRY.
JOHNSON WANTS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THESE ISSUES.
HE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY, INFLATION, JOE BIDEN'S
AGENDA, NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
THE ABORTION RULING THAT CAME
DOWN LAST WEEK.
THAT IS WHAT HE SAYS WILL GET
HIM ANOTHER TERM IN OFFICE.
>> JOINING US NOW CHIEF ANALYST
JEFFREY TOOBIN, LAURA COATES,
DAVID GRIFFIN, GLORIA BORGER.
I WANT TO GET YOUR OPINION ON A
CONVERSATION.
>> I HAD A PROOIFRT CONVERSATION
WITH PAT CIPOLLONE ON THE 3rd OR
THE 4th, THAT PAT WAS CONCERNED
IT WOULD LOOK LIKE WE WERE
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE OR
OBSTRUCTING THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE COUNT.
I APOLOGIZE FOR PROBABLY NOT
BEING VERY FIRM WITH MY LEGAL
TERMS HERE, BUT THAT IT WOULD
LOOK LIKE WE WERE OBSTRUCTING
WHAT WAS HAPPENING ON CAPITOL
HILL, AND HE WAS ALSO WORRIED
THAT IT WOULD LOOK LIKE WE WERE
INCITING A RIOT O ENCOURAGING A
RIOT AT THE CAPITOL.
>> IS THAT THE CLOSEST WE'LL GET
TO PAT CIPOLLONE ACTUALLY
TESTIFYING?
>> PROBABLY, BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT MOMENT IN ITSELF,
BECAUSE ONE OF THE CRUCIAL
MOMENTS HERE IS WHAT DID THE
PEOPLE INVOLVED HERE, STARTING
WITH THE PRESIDENT, KNOW WHAT
WAS ILLEGAL?
YOU KNOW, DID THEY MAKE A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TO COUNT THE
ELECTION HONESTLY, BUT PAT
CIPOLLONE UNDERSTOOD EXACTLY
WHAT THE RISKS WERE HERE, AND
THE THING THAT WE'RE REALLY
MISSING IS WHAT CONVERSATIONS
DID HE HAVE WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP?
PRESUMABLY HE SAID THE SAME
THING TO TRUMP, YOU ARE
VIOLATING THE LAW IF YOU DO WHAT
YOU APPEAR TO BE DOING, AND THE
FACT THAT TRUMP WAS WARNED THAT,
IF HE WAS, WOULD BE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT IN A POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
>> LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONY
TODAY, IT SEEMS LIKE PAT
CIPOLLONE WAS RUNNING AROUND
LIKE CHICKEN LITTLE AT EVERY
MOMENT, SAYING, LOOK, WE'RE
GOING TO GET CHARGED WITH EVERY
CRIME IMAGINABLE.
THIS IS TERRIBLE.
THEY HAVE THIS MEETING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH ALL THE
LAWYERS.
HE SAID, THIS IS A
MURDER-SUICIDE PACT.
WE CANNOT POSSIBLY DO THIS.
YOU CANNOT REPLACE THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH MR. CLARK.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN, PAT
CIPOLLONE WAS SAYING, NO, NO,
NO.
NOBODY WAS LISTENING TO HIM.
DONALD TRUMP AT THAT POINT,
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG, DIDN'T
REALLY LIKE PAT CIPOLLONE VERY
MUCH, EVEN THOUGH HE HAD
DEFENDED HIM ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE DURING IMPEACHMENT, SO
YOU HAVE YOUR WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL TRYING TO SET UP THIS
HUMAN SPEED BUMP TO EVERYTHING,
AND EVERYBODY JUST RAN HIM OVER.
>> YOU KNOW WHO LISTENED?
THE DOJ AT ONE POINT.
YOU MENTIONED THE IDEA OF
WHETHER PAT CIPOLLONE WILL
TESTIFY OR NOT, THINK HOW MANY
TIMES WE HEARD HIS NAME BE
MENTIONED WHEN THE DOJ, RICHARD
ROSEN, MICHAEL DONAHUE.
THE IDEA OF ALL THESE PEOPLE --
HOLD ON, I WONDER IF THIS IS A
VIOLATION OF LAW.
THESE ARE COTEMPLATIVE PEOPLE.
YOU THINK WE MIGHT BE CHARGED?
YEAH, BECAUSE YOU'RE INCITING A
RIOT.
THESE ARE NOT THINGS THAT WERE
OUT OF THIN AIR.
THESE WERE THINGS THAT BECAME
MORE AND MORE PREMEDITATED.
>> WHAT I KNOW FROM MY TIME AT
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE AND WHAT
WENT ALONG WITH TODAY'S HEARING,
YES, PEOPLE GAVE ADVICE TO THE
PRESIDENT.
THE MOMENT THAT STUCK OUT TO ME
WAS PAT TOLD CASSIDY HUTCHINSON,
THE PRESIDENT CANNOT GO TO THE
CAPITOL.
THAT WAS CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT
HIS PRESIDENCY BUT ESPECIALLY
THE FINAL FEW MONTHS.
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT GOT TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IN TERMS
OF, THIS IS ILLEGAL.
YOU CAN'T DO THIS.
THERE WAS A FEAR FACTOR
INVOLVED.
>> THE PORTRAYAL OF THE FINAL
PRESIDENT CASSIDY HUTCHINSON
GAVE, DID IT RING TRUE TO YOU?
DID IT REMIND YOU OF TIMES
THERE, OR WAS IT A DIFFERENT
DONALD TRUMP IN, YOU KNOW, THE
DARK DAYS OF EARLY JANUARY?
>> IT'S KIND OF ALL THE SAME.
BOB COULD SPEAK TO THIS, TOO.
THERE IS A SIDE OF THE PRINCIPAL
THAT IS FUN TO BE AROUND, AND
THERE IS A SIDE OF HIM THAT IS
CRUEL AND UNPREDICTABLE.
I SAW BOTH SIDES WHEN I WAS
THERE, BUT IT DID START TO
UNRAVEL IN THE ENDING DAYS.
AND THE RUDY GIULIANIS AND THE
SIDNEY POWELLS GOT TO HIM AND
THE MESSAGES THAT GIULIANI WAS
SENDING TO HIM INSTEAD OF
TALKING TO HIM AS COUNSEL.
>> HE TOLD PEOPLE DIRECTLY,
THERE IS DANGEROUS.
>> THAT WAS THE SMOKING GUN TO
ME.
HE KNEW THERE WERE WEAPONS.
HERE'S A QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ABOUT
THOSE WEAPONS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH THOSE
WEAPONS ARE BEING PROSECUTED
RIGHT NOW.
AND THEY ARE GETTING ENHANCED
SENTENCES BECAUSE THEY HAD
WEAPONS.
NOW YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES KNOWING THAT
THEY HAD WEAPONS, STILL
ENCOURAGED THEM TO H